hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
how the heck is life treating you it's
been months since we last updated this
series looking at free-to-play titles on
your ps4 you may have recently missed so
let's jump back in and highlight 10
completely free games from the last six
months like usual if you don't see
anything you like on this list I have
another seven episodes full of goodies I
think that's all the housekeeping we
need to do oh no please like and
subscribe to prevent my channel from
dying and let us all know which one of
these games is best on the list anyway
let's do this I'm starting with one of
my personal favorites
dauntless from the outside looking in
the best way to describe dauntless is
like a Monster Hunter clone and that's a
pretty good place to start from as
you'll be hunting down huge behemoth and
use their parts to craft armor and
weapons each behemoth must be approached
differently they all have their own
strengths and weaknesses in addition to
elemental style differences for example
a nice weapon works wonders on a fire
behemoth now months after release
dauntless has added even more content
one of which is the escalation mode in
which we can only take a single set of
gear with us to take on five random
behemoth battles without stopping this
could mean your choice of armor is
weaker than expected oh and did I
mention you'll be fighting two behemoths
at the same time it's quite daunting
note no pun intended at first but after
a while this becomes the best part of
the game I really mean that
a successful escalation run on the
higher settings rewards us with a fight
with a brand new behemoth complete with
new mechanics to learn the best Slayers
in town can also take on Lady Luck's
trials in which she hand picks an
unstoppable behemoth with unique
modifiers enabled and task stars were
taking it down in return for prestige
loot and while all this is going on we
shape our Slayers to look how we want
them to and this is where dauntless will
try to grab your cash with a battle pass
or a hunt pass in this scenario it's
quite tough to deny yourself sweet
armored animals like the ESA's have you
tried it
give us your review in the comments
below the chances of getting through
this list without a battle royale title
pop
are impossible and here's one you may
have missed cuisine Royale this isn't
the typical last-man-standing shooter
this game started as an April Fool's
joke which was so playable it became its
own game yes you are not seeing things
pots and pans and other kitchenware make
up much of the armor here you'll use
waffle irons to protect your rump and
walks to protect your back it's really
strange the maps and weapons are taken
from the game and listed a world war 2
MML shooter making this the strangest
representation of wharfs into orphan
stein another way cuisine royale is
different from other BR shooters is the
class perks and witchcraft I [ __ ] you
not after claiming kills on the
battlefield
these Souls can be used to pull out an
offs attack for example one character
can slow down time another can turn into
a werewolf like creature and tear
through enemies with its claws yeah this
game does not take itself too seriously
at all squatting up with friends is a
great deal of fun I'm not sure if there
is a great deal of longevity here but I
jump back in every so often for the
sheer casual fun and randomness of it
all cuisine Royale let's jump away from
Battle Royale and over to the sequel of
one of the best first-person looter
shooters in history destiny 2 after
Activision and developers Bungie parted
company to attract new players Bungie
created destiny two new light one thing
to note is that this free-to-play
version of the game contains all the
year 1 content of destiny 2 but nothing
after that point this is essentially a
way to attract players in the hopes that
they enjoy the game so much that they
buy the future content going forward in
terms of content the entire base
campaign is here the first rate is here
2 and the raid layers and a decent
amount of player versus player mount to
destiny 2 includes the usual fashion
frame concept popularized by another
free-to-play title warframe which means
by the end game you'll be playing to
unlock and build up a bank of cosmetics
to look exactly how you want to I think
we all know about destiny so let's move
on
here's the most recent free-to-play game
on the market at the time
writing this the Darwin project I've
video breaking down everything so I'll
link it now unlike all other battle
royale titles the Darwin project is much
more about survival as it is hunting
down eliminations the frozen
temperatures must be monitored to keep
our characters warm enough using wood
that we cut from trees to create
campfires on top of that are traps to be
crafted and each character class has key
skills to gain the edge in battle from
scorpion style grappling hooks to
Mercy's wings and even Eli's drone
whatever your play style the game has
you covered in a unique turn the Darwin
project allows for an 11th player to
take part as the match director choosing
to reward people with materials bring in
supply drops and even nuke entire areas
of the map to keep combatants on their
toes if you're looking for a truly
different take on Battle Royale and
something more akin to the Hunger Games
Darwin project is the perfect choice and
it's free right now oh and there's the
usual unlockable styles too don't be
stuck in spandex if that's not your
thing I unlocked a lobster trap strange
how about a mech game
this is Mobile Suit Gundam battle
operation - or if you prefer Mobile Suit
Gundam battle operation - that's a long
ass title anyway the long-running Gundam
series returns with this 6 on 6 team
focused online skirmish to clarify for a
moment if the game is completely free to
play you do not ever need PS + to play
with friends online so ultimately you
and five buddies can play together and
win more often as communication is key
to getting more victories ops 2 uses a
which I'll call it rock paper scissor
style approach with each of the three
class types being superior to one other
and disadvantaged against another this
becomes the basis of attacking and
you'll see on the screen if you have a
superior gundam to take the fight don't
get me wrong you can win with any model
but tactically you'll need to switch up
your play when facing a superior mech
the jack-of-all-trades standard class
will usually be victorious against the
faster melee focused models those faster
mechs will do very well against the
support classes and
support class will regularly outfight
the standard mix you see how it works so
choose your play style whale on your
Falls with a sword or become the
ultimate glass cannon if mix float your
boat give Mobile Suit Gundam battle
operation to a try let's look into the
world of espionage and assassination
hitman 2 starter pack unlike the other
free-to-play titles in this list the
starter pack does require ps+ to play
online
primarily though hitman 2 is a
single-player game so that doesn't
really matter unless you really want to
play with someone online you'll be given
the first part of the story the first
mission will be unlocked which is more
of a tutorial level than you'd expect
and without a doubt it's the weakest
level in the entire game which is a real
shame there are 40 challenges to unlock
5 levels of mastery to grind through and
the game in general is much more slower
paced allowing you to think through your
actions
unlike many games on the market at the
moment I always feel that pittman 2
doesn't get the love it deserves
which is another shame so if this
starter pack brings in new blood I'm
happy to talk about it here I'll link a
few of the missions I played on the
channel to show you some of the
strangest things we can do in this
assassination sandbox and yes like usual
I broke the game completely here's a
game which may not be for many people
but with Dungeons & Dragons Renaissance
going on at the moment I thought it'd be
good to include this is Idol champions
of the Forgotten realm damn it these
titles just keep getting longer idol
champions is about collecting characters
from the Dungeons & Dragons series and
combining their abilities to progress
further down this never-ending Road
ultimately this is a formation strategy
game unlocking those new heroes and
upgrading them constantly to reveal new
abilities on that road will be finding
epic gear and will be battling evolving
foes with ever-changing abilities of
their own managing your squad keeping
them fit for battle and as a close-knit
unit when a single hero falls your
entire unit could be lost in an instant
keeping the group together is really so
important the devs upgrade the game
regularly to include limited time events
with fun favorite D&D characters to add
to your party I know this is a niche
audience but I thought I throw it in
there and yet this is a ported over
mobile
make of that what you will another
free-to-play game for none of your
hard-earned money at all is Genesis a
controller only five-on-five battle
arena I no controller only strange isn't
it this deserves some attention right
let's start with the characters they
look damn impressive each character is
completely unique from the next girls
with big-ass guns they're here animal
human hybrid things they're here too and
alien crossbreeds they're here if you
want to choose from those as well the
mobile runs as you'd expect using
teamwork to take down the opposition
base but here's an addition end the game
early by acquiring enough kills for
example 60 in a match
that's right dare you stick to the plan
of the main objective or go on a kill
rampage to win the game that way on the
other side of Genesis is a single-player
and cooperative PvE mode a brief story
keeps events moving forward as you keep
your team together and push towards
victory over the a I this is also a
great way to learn aspects of the game
and test your tactics all while
absorbing
the story and law how'd you feel about
marbles anyway have they had their time
to shine or do you think they'll be here
forever next up is a Ubisoft game called
growtopia as you can see the primary
audience for this one is children and it
feels much like terraria growtopia of a
64 player servers and is the typical MMO
RPG you'd expect pick up a quest do the
work return for another quest as the
name suggests growtopia is about
building or rather growing a world by
planting seeds and punching blocks to
create your own space I haven't played
it so I'm reading the press release
right now and one of the things that
indicates here is that we can build
lightsabers and even own our own dragons
so there must be quite a bit of depth
here with over 100 minigames to choose
from multiple crafting and trading
options and the best bit of all Ubisoft
costumes are available assassin's creed
anyone so as I haven't tried this one I
need your help please let us know if
this is any good I'll be looking in the
comments for help I think we need to end
on something more adult and bombastic
this is Wolfenstein Youngblood
but whoa whoa whoa don't get your hopes
up too much this is a trial title but
also don't get put off by that bombshell
as it offers cooperative play for you
and a buddy to try together but there's
also another kicker it also needs ps+ to
work with a friend anyway so this is a
complete mess in terms of communication
so let's just concentrate on solo play
because that is free to play you will
fill the shoes of BG Alaska [ __ ] twin
daughters as they liberate Paris from
Nazis come on that does sound epic
doesn't it get ready to hear terrible
one-liners after every kill and speaking
of murder some of the weapons here are
strangely satisfying to use and shoot
again like hitman this game-mode is
attempting to attract players to buy the
full game so unlike the other eight
titles on this list this experience will
be quite limited and replayability
isn't really advantageous so my advice
is simple if you need some gory gameplay
to pass the time give this a download
otherwise steer clear and find a game
with far more content
I suggest dauntless I bloody love it so
there we have it ten more games to add
to our list of free-to-play titles on
the ps4
many of these are cross-platform so give
your Xbox buddies a shout and play
alongside them hopefully one of these
games is worth your precious time and if
it isn't we have so many other episodes
that you can look through right now to
find the perfect game for you I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade come talk to me
on Twitter I'm Adam granade over there
and I'll see you next time
[Music]